- Please answer. Please, please.
- Ugh, Gisele, I gotta get this over with. It’s Jules.
OH, HI, JULIAN!
- [Speaking in gruff voice] No, it’s Bruce Arians. See, I have the hat.
Tom, we’re firing you.
- Jules, I know it’s you. I have your number saved.
- [Speaking in own voice] You finally saved my number!
[Back to gruff voice] It’s definitely Bucs coach
Bruce Arians.
No risk it, no biscuit! I let my coaches go home
after work! Carson Palmer!
- Jules, I can see all the framed photos of us behind you.
- WE’RE STICKING WITH JAMEIS SINCE APPARENTLY YOU
ALSO HAVE NO PROBLEM THROWING IT ALL AWAY.
[Sobbing]
- Julian, you’re one of my favorite work friends.
- You mean it, Tom?
- Sure.
- I wish I could come over and give you a big hug.
- Yeah...oh but quarantine, right?
- Right. Right. So why the f--k TAMPA BAY?
- I love the Tampa...culture.
[Under his breath] And the Niners wouldn’t let me ruin Garoppolo’s life again.
- PLEASE, PLEASE STAY! I’LL STOP SELLING T-SHIRTS WITH YOUR FACE ON THEM!
- Oh uh, we’re breaking up, Jules! Sorry.
- NO, HERE, LET’S INCLUDE COACH.
- Why am I suddenly SnapFacing?
I was watching teen trick-shot videos on TokTik.
It’s what counts as game film in our new reality.
- COACH, YOU’RE ON WITH ME AND YOUR NO. 1 QUARTERBACK!
- Oh, hi, Jarrett Stidham.